(bell rings)
(upbeat rock music)
- Somebody get over there.
- Back over, back over.
- Yeah.
- That's how we did it
in the 90s, son.
(upbeat rock music)
- [Randal] I can't
catch my breath, man.
- Really? Should
I try mouth stuff?
- What is this, a Tinder date?
Get off of me.
Oh, shit!
- Mr. Dante.
- I need an ambulance
at the Quick Stop.
(siren blaring)
- You saved my life, man.
Wish I had a life worth saving.
- What are you talking about?
- [Randal] I sit around
and watch the same movies,
over and over.
- I always thought you could
have made a cool movie.
- You're right.
I'm living on borrowed time.
No more watching movies.
I'm gonna make a movie.
(heart monitor flatline tone)
(upbeat rock music)
- [Elias] What's the
movie gonna be about?
- It's about him, working here.
- Meta.
- [Randal] Everything in this
script is something either me
or someone I know said.
- I'm not even...
- Supposed to.
- Be here today.
- Maybe Jay and Silent
Bob could be characters.
- Jay and Silent Bob are
like C-3PO and R2-D2.
They've been here
since the first movie,
which was the last
time they were cool,
but they've been with
the franchise so long,
they still give them cameos and
put them on the lunch boxes.
- Snoochie boochies!
♪ Please tell me why ♪
(upbeat rock music)
- [Becky] I believe in you.
- You should put in
that stuff you used to say
about the Death
Star contractors.
- Get sued by
Disney? No way.
♪ Sleeping with my clothes on ♪
- Now that's what I call acting.
(witch laughing)
- Take off your pants.
(upbeat rock music)
- Ah, what the hell is this?
- I added a scene
where you get shot.
- I'm not letting you kill
me off in the third act.
What if there's a sequel?
- A sequel?
What am I a hack?
(upbeat rock music)
- I think it needs more weed.